[Music]
so
is it always like that it's never like
that
that is a clip from everything
everything the box office hit based on
the mega bestseller
by nicola yoon ewen burst onto the scene
in 2015 with a book that has now sold
more than two
million copies she followed that a year
later with the sun is also a star
also turned into a successful film and
even launched her own book imprint
now she's back with instructions for
dancing about a young girl who can see
into the future
as she grows up in los angeles that's
where we met yoon
just before publication i love the fact
that people here
want to make art and have these big
dreams
as a kid nicola yoon excelled at math
which helps explain why she eventually
took a job in finance
she hated every minute of it my soul
left my body
every time i went into those buildings
just like you could see it
flying away and then when i had my
little girl i decided to try
to really try because i thought one day
i was gonna tell her
you know follow your passions have a big
dream
and i wasn't following my passion at all
by the time she ditched her investment
management career
nicola who's married to fellow young
adult writer david yoon
had already been getting up at 4am every
day for three years to write what became
her breakout bestseller
everything everything about a girl with
a medical condition who's not allowed to
leave her house
who falls in love i like this room my
mom
built it so that i could feel like i was
outside in 2017 it was turned into a
movie starring amandla stenberg
i'm going really fast i'm only 30.
can you go faster in some ways
everything everything
changed the face of why a fiction and
film
black characters often sidekicks and
hollywood productions
are always the main protagonist in
yoon's work
when kids come up to you and say i'm not
used to seeing people who look like me
or reading about people who look like me
in books and when they
tell you how much that means to them
yeah it means a lot to you
it does it really it really really does
because
maddie and everything everything looks
the way she does because my little girl
looks like that
so i'm from jamaica my husband's korean
american
and so she's like this little mixed kid
and maddie and everything everything is
also mixed
yoon's second effort also a hit book
turned into a movie
was the sun is also a star you met me
yesterday get over
it i don't want to get over it but you
should i'm not going to get over it
part of falling in love is falling in
love with yourself
and i make sure the girls in the books
know that you know like
you're not defined by this relationship
like you have to love yourself too
now she's written instructions for
dancing about a shy hero named evie
who realizes she has a chilling
superpower she can see how any
relationship
will end so evie her genesis is because
of what was happening in my life
while i was writing that book my mom was
very sick and
my father-in-law was diagnosed with
cancer and he died
and so what i was thinking about while i
was writing this book is
why do we fall in love like why do we
let ourselves love people
when we know things are going to end
evie's love interest takes the opposite
approach
no matter what's going to happen he
dives right in living
every moment in full how much do you
remember growing up in jamaica
i remember a lot um i was allowed to be
whoever i wanted to be because honestly
everyone is black there
and i remember the difference of coming
to america
that was the first time i felt different
when i was 11.
growing up in jamaica and brooklyn yoon
never thought she'd get any of these
opportunities
a chance to be a new york times number
one bestseller on her very first try
and to sit on glamorous movie sets it's
been
just wonderful visiting sets like they
employ
so many people based on my little book i
mean that's amazing it's cool
uh i got to show my little girl you can
make art and it could become this whole
thing right for a long time i thought
you could not make a living making art
but i got to show her like you can make
things and like
you know remake the world and that was
really really wonderful
i have to make a diorama after a year of
mostly remote learning
yoon's daughter penny is now back in
school the family is back at restaurants
including the waffle joint just two
blocks from yoon's home that features
prominently in instructions for dancing
how many times has penny been there
penny basically was born there
okay but we've been there a lot and it
was
the first place we went to when we could
finally go somewhere post-pandemic
did the pandemic change your writing
plans or outlook at all
weirdly it made me write more because it
was like my safe space
so i wrote another book during the
pandemic are there different kinds of
writing that you want to do or do you
feel like you're locked in
and like this is your wheelhouse um so
the book i wrote during pandemic is an
adult book
it's not romantic at all my poor agent
she has no idea what's coming
she will know she will now um
heads up yeah and then david and i are
working on the fantasy book together
actually oh cool
um and so that's been really fun writing
because we've always wanted to write
together
i'm nicola yoon and i wrote this i'm
david yun and i wrote this known for
their fun
social media videos the younes are
partners who share a combined passion
and along the way have found a combined
millions of readers
i would learn to see the beauty i guess
in the journey
rather than the destination i love
writing
i mean it makes me really genuinely
miserable sometimes
like i'm impossible when i'm in the
middle of a book
um but i love it i don't know how else
to be
so i'm sort of stuck with it
i'm not the normal market for wyatt who
is
romance novels but it's worth checking
out because her work resonates so much
with so many people and means so much to
them including you
oh i mean you know i you you explained
to me
that that teenagers aren't necessarily
her audience
yeah no i mean the y market is generally
i mean it's a lot of times
it's people in their 20s early 30s or
even 40s or 50s how about that
young at heart she's amazing i loved her
thank you so much for that